Wow there's actually a few things I want
to make videos on ultimately I live in a
world of chaos I see a bunch of things
and I just go I feel like making a video
on that so I guess I'm going to do that
so I'm gonna make a video about Michael
Bay's newest movie trailer transformers
age of extinction and in this new
trailer for the newest Michael Bay
monstrosity you see the age of
Transformers is over which is a really
cool premise and this trailer looks cool
let's not kid ourselves though Michael
Bay trailers usually look cool but the
dudes movie content makes for really
cool-looking trailers Mark Wahlberg gets
this busted ass truck because he's going
to sell it out for parts B's like he's
found his graceful so Optimus Prime is
this busted shell of a truck like
bumblebee was a busted shell of a car in
the first movie so ultimately Optimus
Prime is like bumblebee these government
guys show up in smoke monster starts
giving marky-mark [ __ ] which is fine and
dandy these guys look like dicks they
look like they're serious boy let's not
kid ourselves in the movie they're gonna
be the comic relief the Transformers are
all in a rut they're all like oh I mean
no one needs us anymore and Stanley
Tucci is like no one needs you anymore
and I'll say this right now even if this
movie is [ __ ] Stanley Tucci is gonna be
really good in it because he's that guy
I always say it Stanley Tucci Idris Elba
the two guys where if you're like the
movies [ __ ] you'll be like but they were
good knit but of course big bad
Decepticons are gonna show up so we're
gonna need the Autobots again we're
gonna be like I'm sorry I don't
and after that Michael Bay isms shits
blowing up streets are blowing up even
the [ __ ] grass blows up the doting
this trailer is so dark those like Oh
dev no no you know kind of like the tone
and Transformers Revenge of the Fallen I
can't take Michael Bay trailers at face
value tomorrow that was the one that did
it that one broke my back you remember
that [ __ ] if you saw the trailer for
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen the
first one it looks like a horror movie I
will put a link below so you can check
it out so like that beatin wife who
didn't do the dishes I feel like it's
just gonna end badly for me if I get my
hopes up like it's gonna be different
this time is not what I love is I think
this could probably be the final trailer
because this is the plot we don't need
Autobots and then bad guys show up and
we do and then [ __ ] blows up what else
do you want in the trailer what else can
we possibly say to convey to you what
the movies going to be about and I know
I'm probably pissing off Transformers
movie fans and I get it you're free to
like any movie you want it's fine I'm
not saying you're a douchebag for liking
transformer movies
movies as a whole I mean you gotta admit
they're not good they're guilty-pleasure
movies at best which is fine I rock that
streetfighter blu-ray in my shelf it's
real but I know it's not good this movie
has potential but I'm not gonna go hmm
maybe it'll be good
what is Optimus Prime fighting Grimlock
is that Grimlock I thought it was
Grimlock and Optimus Prime's all around
it smacks him in the face I'm like why
would Optimus Prime bitch-slap Grimlock
maybe he was out of line of some but it
looks like they actually fight before he
rides him like a knight then again
Devastator had balls in the second movie
so I who knows so the trailer for
transformers age of extinction have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]